alright I'm here with Edwin diamond you
were fantastic on the show tonight first
of all and I was talking to at the after
party here and you said something that
terrified me which is the more you hear
about or the more you know about these
you know nuclear disasters and dangers
posed by them the more terrifying it is
I thought that was really comforting so
thank you for talking to that and I'll
never sleep again always looking to help
yeah and you're working on a book right
now it's called Fukushima the story of a
nuclear disaster which is for kids right
it's a children's exact yeah you know
underrated recommend right but seriously
yeah actually we finished the book I
wrote it with two co-authors one is my
colleague at the union of concerned
scientists Dave lockdown and the other
is a very skilled journalist Susan
Stranahan there's a lot of experience
writing about nuclear power issues okay
and so the books coming out in February
and it's being published by the new
press alright well just probably pick
that up and learn about what's going on
and the focus of the book is how to
prevent something like Fukushima from
happening in the future is that right or
the story of how it happened it's we
tell the story of Fukushima we try to
explain as best we can the technical
aspects of the accident put in a
narrative style so we involved we talked
about how the workers responded how the
government responded how the US Nuclear
Regulatory Commission responded
so we try to lay out the technical
explanation and then we talk about the
politics behind nuclear power the
history of nuclear power regulation and
half of the limitations on how nuclear
power is regularly directly contributed
to an attitude that led to Fukushima
this is the attitude that accidents this
bad just can't happen and so we don't
have to spend a lot of money trying to
prevent accidents that we don't think
happened and this has led to a
complacency in the regulation of nuclear
power which is a very very dangerous
thing to say it's more than just the
earthquake the tsunami that caused the
sort of disaster was just the culture of
nuclear now offers it's a it's a complex
mix of the design and the reactor the
way it was cited the way it was licensed
in the way was run and the operations in
regulation have everything to do with
culture and attitude and is this book
directed at the consumers the public to
get them motivated to come out in favor
of you know more regulation or safer
products or is it who are you trying to
reach with this we're trying to get an
audience of people who want to learn
more about the accident what happened
the consequences of the accident and
what can be done to prevent the next
Fukushima from happening especially here
in the United States and we have the
opportunity to do it but we don't think
that the Nuclear Regulatory Commission
in the nuclear industry really has the
will to carry through there for
how much fallout no pun intended do you
think we'll continue to experience from
this Fukushima incident is it going to
go on for decades and decades or is this
something that you think that they can
contain in the near future well I think
the Japanese have discovered that you
can't just put it on the back burner
proceed with restarting all your other
nuclear power plants come up with plans
to export new nuclear power to other
countries and not deal with Fukushima
because that site is going to cause
problems for many decades to come and if
you don't deal with it appropriately at
the beginning it is going to keep
reminding you that it's there and so so
it's it's a site unless the Japanese can
demonstrate that they can stabilize the
site that they can decommission it if
they can stop routine and unplanned
radioactive releases they can control it
unless they can do those things there's
no credible argument why we should
believe the next plan is going to be
safe catch well thank you so much for
coming out the head of alignment check
out his book Fukushima a story of a
nuclear disaster thank you some sock you
later blizzard okay